convicted of manslaughter
pc benjamin monk left court knowing next
week
he faces jail the man he killed former
staff footballer dalian atkinson
who died after pc monk tasered him then
kicked him in the head
days afterwards he tried to explain why
he did it
and i'd formed the opinion that i was
going to the only way i could keep this
man on the ground
to ensure our safety i was going to kick
him it was a brutal act
that even then he was trying to minimize
claiming it was done in self-defense
so could you describe to me the kick
that you did yeah of course it's
basically
right footed um pulled my right foot
back
kicked him in the in the area which i
believe to be a shoulder area
can i show yeah absolutely it's
literally
it's literally there okay
where did that make contact i don't know
the evidence was clear
marks from the imprints of pc monk's
boot lace were found in two places on
dalian atkinson's forehead
he died soon afterwards his family have
waited nearly
five years for someone to be held
responsible for his death
there's many relief we're just relief
that it's finally finally over
it's been a long really long journey on
the night that dalian died
he was vulnerable and unwell and he
needed medical attention
instead he received violence and died
with pc monk's boot lace
prince bruised on his forehead
we have been sickened to hear pc monk
try to minimalize the force he used on
dalian
and exaggerate the threat that dalian
posed
on the night dalian atkinson died police
were called by a neighbour of his father
in telford
hello hello i'm i'm not sure
um what's actually happening but
um i've just heard some noise so muslim
looked down the window
and there's a car pulled up outside from
an old man's house
and then there's somebody shouting and
then he went back to his car and went
back to the door kicked it
[Applause]
um
[Music]
when the police arrived there was a
confrontation pc monk used his taser
the first time he fired it it didn't
work he fired it a second time
again no effect but when he fired it the
third time it did work
dalian atkinson fell into the road pc
monk continued to hold the trigger
the taser was deployed for 33 seconds
the normal cycle of a taser is just five
seconds
the independent office of police conduct
confirmed a review of taser use
is currently underway the jury is still
considering their verdict in the case of
pc mary ellen betley smith who's on
trial for assault
the assistant chief constable of west
mercier police gave her reaction to the
conviction
of pc monk words alone cannot express
the deep shock and regret that i feel
that i must stand here and address you
today because a west mercier police
officer
has been found criminally responsible
for dalian's death
this is the first conviction of a
serving officer for manslaughter
following a death during police contact
in england
for more than 30 years for the atkinson
family
it's brought justice for dalian becky
johnson sky news telford